welcome back following news of the
sweeping verdict handed down in the
favor of johnny depp we're hearing now
from top legal experts in the field law
and crime network founder dan abrams
says the verdict was vindication for
johnny depp and only a token win for
amber heard
remember this is a case where he sued a
publication in london where the standard
is harder to win and a judge came back
and said no
we he believed that that johnny depp was
a wife beater on 12 of 14 counts now you
have a jury here of seven people five
men and two women coming back and saying
that johnny depp was defamed on all
three of the counts
i mean this i think is a real surprise
to a lot of people now i had talked
about previously the possibility of both
of them quote unquote winning but i
think this quote win for amber heard is
really a token win putting aside the
money right putting aside the fact that
it's 15 million for him 2 million for
her
that's not just the issue here you know
it sounds like the the issue the jurors
had with the statement made by the
lawyer for johnny depp was about the
fact that she got together with her
friends effectively conspiring so maybe
they didn't believe that aspect of it
but it seems to me that the takeaway
from this case is these jurors believed
johnny depp and they didn't believe
amber heard i don't think there is any
other way to interpret all of these
verdicts together
law and crime network also spoke with
kathleen zellner a renowned attorney who
consulted with depp's team early on she
says amber heard lost the case because
her story was not credible compared to
depp's
i really think it came down to
credibility i just uh i think her case
failed
uh
and looking at it as a criminal attorney
it failed on the forensic evidence those
um
beatings and abuse that she described
did not happen
i've been doing
criminal cases for over 30 years and
the
forensic evidence simply wasn't there
she she just did not suffer the injuries
forget about having witnesses i can
understand
you know that abuse victims don't have
first-hand
uh knowledge witnesses present but the
evidence wasn't there there just was not
the forensic evidence to support which
he was claiming the second thing because
i've represented a lot of sexual abuse
victims over the years
she wasn't afraid of him and i think
camille vasquez did a beautiful job of
of laying all that out not only in the
cross-examination but in the closing i
mean she wasn't afraid of him uh she was
you know
taunting him
uh she was very aggressive um and so her
case just collapsed and and you know
that falls at her feet
she just was not credible that's why she
lost
all right before i get to the questions
i want to say thank you thank you to
everyone who watch along crime daily and
follow this case
every one of us from guests to host
executive producers worked so hard on
this and thank you for following us here
and and keeping up to date with all the
the the uh the case now weeks of
covering has led us here to a full
victory for johnny depp and somewhat of
a partial one for amber heard so i want
to know for both of you what are your
final thoughts on this case both in
terms of small picture and big tracy
let's first start off with your thoughts
well i think that i i hope that we are
at an inflection point in this country
where we return to critical thinking and
look at evidence before we banish people
from their professions the second thing
is that i think that this is a
cautionary tale for lawyers and
it should stand as a way to warn them uh
from making their statements in the
media in a way that could in fact create
liability for their clients
absolutely because if
i mean doctor you're perfect if waldman
didn't say that amber heard doesn't have
a single claim that she wins terry same
question your thoughts
actually from a technical standpoint i
do think the jury got it right and as
both dan and tracy said that one
statement where they found in favor of
amber heard was because they didn't see
it was a conspiracy but everything else
johnny depp won and he got his
reputation back on a bigger picture
level
i think that people are not going to be
afraid to bring a claim as far as
domestic violence is concerned whether
you're male or female because if you
have an actual case and you tell the
truth you can prevail we saw that with r
kelly we saw that with harvey weinstein
and here the person who was telling this
story was lying so i think overall
people are still going to bring their
cases absolutely and i'll have bill
cosby to that one as well thank you
doctor thank you terry and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america